this year the Yale professor said some
things that scandalized Venetian and
made headlines all over the country
writing in The Wall Street Journal she
told the world that her daughters were
not allowed to get any grade less than
an a they had to be the number one
student in every subject except Jim and
drama she recommended calling children
garbage when they failed to measure up
she said parents of overweight children
should address them as hey fatty she
talked about how when her daughter kept
making mistakes in a piano piece she
called her lazy cowardly self indulgent
and pathetic and threatened to give away
her dollhouse to the Salvation Army she
said her children had to be absolutely
perfect because nothing is fun until
you're good at it overnight professor
amy chua became a celebrity her book
battle hymn of the tiger mother was on
magazine covers and bestseller lists and
chill herself was all over the
television and Internet there are many
reasons why choose but dominated the
media and surged the top of the
bestseller lists some of it may have
been a kind of racial fascination with
this character she created the tough
Chinese tiger mother who demanded
absolute perfection or else some of it
probably had to do with the fact that
books on motherhood touch a nerve some
of it was undoubtedly the fact that she
had a really good publicist but I think
for a lot of people and certainly a lot
of people here at Yale where articles on
to it quickly filled the Yale Daily News
the book struck a chord because a lot of
us have tiger mothers inside us
regardless of what our own mothers were
like many of us have an inner tiger
mother monologue that tells us you have
to get an A and everything you have to
be the best in the class when we can't
measure up to the cultural ideal of
beauty we hear a voice saying hey fatty
you're garbage
when we make a mistake something inside
says you're lazy cowardly self indulgent
and pathetic this inner monologue of
perfectionism does a lot of work for us
we may believe it helped get us to the
Ivy League we may rely on it to carry us
through our future careers but it takes
a toll on us as well when we're no
longer the best in the class we worry
that we aren't ourselves anymore and
when we're trying so hard to be the best
we can forget to eat or sleep or pay
attention to the needs of those around
us sometimes we interpret silence as
criticism sometimes we interpret praise
as criticism sometimes when people love
us unconditionally we have trouble
accepting their love worst of all a lot
of the time we have trouble hearing
anything except that ruthless inner
monologue that relentless voice telling
us be perfect be perfect perfectionism
is a problem and yet here is Jesus on
the Sermon on the mat telling us be
perfect as your heavenly Father is
perfect it's easy for those of us who
are perfectionists to interpret this
commandment as a confirmation of our
inner perfectionist voice as yet another
impossibly high standard that we have to
try to meet but this time instead of
getting an A which is hard enough we
have to be perfect like God which is
impossible we already know we are going
to fail at this and we may worry that
now in addition to that nagging voice in
our heads saying I can't believe you got
a B+ on that midterm I can't believe you
haven't been to the gym this week we're
going to have the voice of Jesus in our
head saying things like I can't believe
you didn't give your coat to that
homeless person on Chapel Street
I can't believe you don't love that mean
girl as much as you do your best friend
but I am here to tell you that Jesus is
not a tiger mother Jesus mail of God's
dazzling perfection but he is not a
perfectionist when Jesus was preaching
perfection on the mountain he was not
trying to reinforce our own
self-involved self-loathing inner
monologues instead he was trying to
interrupt them he was trying to replace
our own imperfect perfectionism with a
new vision God's vision so what is
Jesus's vision of perfection and how is
it different from the perfectionism that
were used to the most important way that
it's different and the most liberating
thing about it is that it's not actually
about us not us by ourselves anyway the
perfection that Jesus describes in this
passage and throughout the Sermon on the
Mount is not about the flawlessness of
isolated individuals this perfection is
not anything that we can attain through
solitary striving or through hours spent
in private prayer or at the library
instead it is always about perfection
expressed in relationship to others
perfection that's only possible in the
midst of a community perfection about
love for others and love for God
beginning with the Beatitudes and
continuing with his commands to be salt
and light Jesus has been preaching a
sermon about how his followers need to
be so transformed by love so full of a
rational mercy an unshakable peace that
they will serve as a kind of flavor
enhancer of the world adding
deliciousness it will become a beacon of
shining warmth and brightness instead of
succeeding perfectly according to the
world standards instead of trying to
perfectly obey the letter of the law
Jesus's followers are to act in ways
that are unintelligible by the world
standards that only make sense in the
light of God in their generosity and
their sense of abundance they will give
freely and their sense of security and
God's love for them they will find
themselves able to love people that it
makes no sense for them to love and as
we learn next week they will be so
oriented to God that they will forget to
worry instead of relying on their inner
monologue and their own standards they
will rely on God for their daily bread
and their daily grades and their daily
sense of purpose and meaning and their
daily motivation but more importantly
they will often forget about themselves
entirely in their curiosity about the
communities around them their love for
others and their desire to help keep
God's kingdom come to earth a lot of us
spend a lot of energy trying to get
Jesus's vision of perfection to fit with
our own self-centered vision that energy
is wasted energy a lot of us spend a lot
of time trying to perfectly measure up
to Yale standards while trying to follow
God as well that time is wasted time you
cannot serve both God and Yale our
purpose as members of the Yale community
is not to orient ourselves to the stark
standards of grades and academic honors
and the more nebulous but still harsh
standards of social acceptance instead
our mission is to pursue a different
perfection entirely a friend of mine who
teaches Renaissance literature here told
me that in the 1600s the word perfect
meant full or complete we are perfect
when our hearts are full of love when we
are participating in life with our whole
soul and with all our mind and strength
the wonderful thing about this kind of
perfection is that a teaspoon can be as
completely full as
ocean floor God may be an ocean and we
may be just a teaspoon but we can still
partake in God's perfection by being
full to the brim with love in some ways
I have a special perspective on Yale
perfectionism because right now and both
a student and a teacher I'm taking
classes at the divinity school but I'm
also a TF for English and American
Studies classes in Yale College as a
student I sometimes struggle to silence
my inner monologue when I write I often
have to remind myself that Jesus is
perfection as the kind that counts but
as a teacher I know exactly what a
perfect section is and it's not one
where everyone gets A's neither is it a
section where I have all the answers and
always make amazing lesson plans that
turn out exactly the way I planned no
the perfect section is one where the
students and I are fully present not
just physically present completely
present they may not always like the
reading but they care about it they
contribute to the conversation even if
they're not quite sure they're right
they come with questions and they leave
with questions they listen to each other
with attentiveness and respect when they
meet with me to talk about their papers
it's obvious they're thinking through
ideas that really matter to them the
class is giving them a window into
worlds they haven't known before to
Kenzie and England Harlem in the 1920s
Vietnam in the 1970s and this is helping
them understand their own world in new
ways they may be freshmen who have never
written a college paper before or they
may be seniors who seem to have
everything figured out but either way
they learn and grow over the course of
the semester and through participating
in conversations with them and reading
their work I am learning and growing too
and on the last day of class even though
we're all tired and antsy and ready for
vacation we have a sense
shared satisfaction new friendships have
been formed new favorite authors have
been discovered new English or history
majors have been born and as we say our
goodbyes and maybe talk a little bit
about what's going to be on the final we
feel like we've been traveling together
and we've made progress together on our
journeys we've helped each other along
the way this is the perfection that
Jesus is talking about a collective
expression of wholeheartedness fullness
and completeness that may involve some
mistakes along the way there's much more
I could say about this but for now I
want to close with a part of the gospel
it would be easy to read right by the
part that says God makes the Sun Rise on
the evil and on the good and sends rain
on the righteous and on the unrighteous
on Friday when the temperature
skyrocketed into the 50s and the snow
finally started to melt a little bit you
could walk down the street and see
smiling people people who had taken off
their hats and scarves for the first
time in months people with hope in their
eyes the sunshine and warmth belonged to
everyone sometimes when we're fighting
to attain worldly perfection and a Place
in the Sun it can seem like there's a
limited amount of sunshine in the world
and not everyone gets it and we have to
earn it ourselves when we're in the grip
of perfectionism we can forget that God
makes the Sun Shine on all of us
regardless of whether we deserve it or
whether we feel like we deserve it our
perfect God warms us all with the same
Sun and washes us all with the same rain
some theologians call this common grace
it's the grace that God extends to all
of us all the time regardless of what we
do or what we don't do simply because we
exist amen
you